I know how great he is
I know how great Joker is
certain guys in this league that play
the game a certain way
a certain way that I like to play the
game as well
and he's one of them
where you are always off balance when
you're going to player like that because
his ability to score rebound shoot
um
he sees plays before they happen
it's not many guys in our league like
that
so
you already knew you was going against a
beast once you uh wants to the series
started and not only just about his game
everybody gets cracked up into his his
stats but I don't think a lot of people
talk about like this part of his game
well maybe that's not talking about
because a lot of people don't understand
it
but I do easy special